Coronavirus isn't just a threat to your health, it's a threat to the economy.
As infection numbers ticked up, the stock
market had it's worst day in 12 years.
So it's probably not surprising that President Trump has promised very dramatic
plans to help keep the economy up and running, Basically, we're talking about a new stimulus.
But that raises just a different question, can you really solve a public health problem with economic policy?
With me today to talk about the coronavirus economy and what to do about it is Veronqiue de Rugy.
She's a senior research fellow at the Mercatus
Center at George Mason University,
and a frequent contributor to Reason Magazine.
Veronique, thanks for coming to talk with
me.
Thanks for having me.
So, isn't this the government's job
to step in times of economic crisis and help people out?
What is wrong with President Trump saying that he wants dramatic intervention measures?
So the problem isn't so much that the government would do something in terms of emergency,
the question is what can they really do. And that's really actually, that's really the big question.
Because this is not an emergency like we've seen, this is not the Great Recession,
this is not a natural disaster that keeps the whole city under water, it's very different.
It's a public health issue with economic consequences and it's kind of unclear what the best way to go about it.